[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
بولس
تلوحوا بالنوويه مجددا يصف تهديدات موسكو
النوويه بالخطيره وغير المسؤوله
وزراء خارجات الدول الخليجيه يحثون واشنطن
على التوصل لحل شامل ودائم لقضيه فلسطين
نحو ثلاثه ملايين تصريح للعمره في رمضان
حتى الان وتوافد كبير على المسجد الحرام
في الرابعه ايضا
[موسيقى]
بدا الرصد الالي لمخالفات ملاحقات وتعطيل
حركه سيارات الاسعاف في السعوديه
موجه امطار متفاوته تعلق الدراسه في
ثمانيه عشره مدينه سعوديه وتوقعات
باستمرار الحاله الجويه ليوم الغد
وصباح الفلديدات روسيا النوويه بالخطيره
وغير المسؤوله وقال ان التصريحات عن دور
الحلف باي تصعيد مضلله واكدنيت انه متيقظ
ويراقب تهديدات موسكو النوويه عن كثب كما
قال انه لم يسجل اي تغيرات في موقف روسيا
النووي تدفع الخلفه للتحرك والتعديل وضعه
النووي
نووي كلمه خفيفه على اللسان لكنها ثقيله
في ميزان الحرب بل مستقبلي كوكب الارض
بين الحين والاخر يخرج الرئيس الروسي
ليتحدث عن الاسلحه النوويه موجهه للكلام
الى خصومه الغربيين
في كل مره يرفع بوتين التحدي عاليا فضغطه
زر واحده كافيه لمحو بلد باكمله بل اكثر
خبراء يرون ان تلويح الزعيم الروسي
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه ما هو الا هروب
من المشاكل الداخليه التي يتخبط فيها جراء
الازمه الناتجه عن العقوبات الاقتصاديه
الدوليه على بلاده بعد اطلاق العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
فسيد الكرملين يلجا الى سياسه حافه
الهاويه لاجبار خصومه على الجلوس لطاوله
المفاوضات يقول مراقبون الزعيم الروسي هدد
في غير ما مره باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
اذا اراد الغرب القضاء على روسيا وفق
تعبيره فلعالم بلا روسيا حسب عقيده موسكو
بوتين سبق ان هدد باحتمال نشوب حرب نوويه
خلال العام الماضي خاصه كلما تعثرت عمليته
العسكريه في اوكرانيا فالقوه الروسيه تقصف
المدن الاوكرانيه من الجو لكن الحرب
البريه لا تحقق الكثير من التقدم حديث
زعيم الكريم الجديد القديم عن الاسلحه
النوويه ياتي ايضا بعد اصدار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال بحقه فهل
سيفعلها بوتين ويلجا لاستخدام اسلحه لا
تبقي ولا تذر ام ان كلامه مجرد تهديدات
فقط لا ترقى الى مرحله الفعل بلال
البستاني العربيه
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
طعمه كاتيا مرحبا بك ما الذي يتم الحديث
عنه في موسكو اليوم بخصوص استخدام روسيا
للسلاح النووي بعد التصريحات والتهديدات
الاخيره من كبار المسؤولين الروس هل
بالفعل هذه المره هناك جديه لهذه
التهديدات تم خطوات تكتيكيه كما يرى البعض
مرحبا خالد بالفعل تصريحات هي تتوالى من
قبل المسؤولين الروس واخرها على رئيس على
لسان الرئيس الروسي الذي كان قد اعلن يوم
امس ان روسيا تنوي الانتهاء من بناء مجمع
لنشر الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه في على
الاراضي
البيلاروسيه الحليفه لروسيا طبعا هذه
الخطوه كما راها بعض الخبراء هي تاتي كرد
كخطوه رد على
خطوه لندن التي كانت قد اعلنتها منذ فتره
بانها تنوي ارسال قذائف اليورانيوم الى
القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا هذه الخطوه هي
طبعا حتى الان تعتبر فقط على مستوى
التصعيد السياسي كما يراها الشارع الروسي
طبعا هناك تخوف من امكانيه استخدام
الاسلحه ولكن كما قال الرئيس
استخدام هذه الاسلحه فقط سيكون في حال كان
هناك تهديد او ستكون كرد على
امكانيه استخدام القوات الاوكرانيه لمثل
القذائف اليورانيوم التي ايضا اعتبر
الرئيس الروسي انها ليست من اسلحه التدمير
الشامل ولكنها تؤثر على
المواطنين الاوكرانيين وعلى الاراضي
الزراعيه لذلك روسيا قد تتخذ ايضا خطوات
في هذا الصدد وتقوم باستخدام نفس نوع
الاسلحه التي تمتلكه ايضا موسكو بالاضافه
لذلك كانت روسيا دعت مرارا واخيرا على
لسان رئيسين الروسي والصيني في خلال
قيمتهما الاخيره بان يتم طبعا عدم
الامتناع على عدم ارسال الاسلحه النوويه
الى دول ثالثه وهذا ما تحدثت عنه موسكو
برارا لان واشنطن او موسكو تتهم واشنطن
بانها تقوم بارسال الاسلحه النوويه ونشرها
الموجوده في جميع دول الاتحاد الاوروبي من
بينها طبعا المانيا وايطاليا بالاضافه الى
وجود ايضا تهديد عسكري بيلاروسيا على
الحدود مع بولندا ووجود قوات لحلف الناتو
على الاراضي هناك خالد خطوه يعني نشرس
نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا ايضا كاتيا هل
ينظر اليها على انها كذلك باتت او خطوه
ربما تقرب من استخدام هذا النوع من
الاسلحه في ميدان المعركه في في اوكرانيا
حقيقه خالد هي لربما هذه الخطوه لحفظ
التوازن او لتشكيل تهديد سياسي ضد
اوكرانيا بالاخص ان كما ذكرت ان اولا
بولندا تقوم بنشر
قوات حلف منتشره على الحدود ما بين بولندا
وبين بيلاروسيا بالاضافه الى وجود ايضا
تهديد من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه الاراضي
البيرروسيه وكما تعلم ان بيلاروسيا هي
حليف او دوله حليفه لروسيا وكان الرئيس
البيلاروسيا ايضا من جانبه كان قد اكد او
قال ان هناك خطوره من امكانيه وصول اسلحه
او قذائف تحمل اليورانيوم الى القوات
الاوكرانيه لذلك سيكون لدى بيلاروسيا ايضا
الحق المطالبه بالحصول على اسلحه نوويه
لذلك تاتي هذه الخطوه كما تحدث ايضا بوتين
بانها تلبيه لطلب الرئيس الروسي لطلب
الرئيس البيلاروسي بنشر الاسلحه النوويه
تكتيكيه لحمايه البلاد من اي تهديد خارجي
خالد
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو مراسله العربيه
حول التعاون الروسي الصينيين في الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان تكون بلاده بصدد
بناء حلف عسكري مع صين متهما خلف شمال
الاطلسيه بالسعي نحو تشكيل حلف عسكريين
عالمي منتشر في كل القارات
نحن لا نبني حلفا عسكريا مع الصين نعم
لدينا تعاون في مجال صناعه العسكريه لا
نخفي ذلك ليس هذا الامر سرا لدينا تعاون
عسكري وفي مجال التكوين ايضا ومع دول اخرى
وهذا مستمر حتى الان
وزير الخرجات الروسيسير ان الولايات
المتحده تجاوزت كل الحدود الاخلاقيه في
محاوله للتاكيد هيمنتها واضاف بانه يمكن
توقع اي شيء من الولايات المتحده في
محاوله للتاكيد هيمنتها مشيرا لان واشنطن
تجاوزت بالفعل جميع خطوط اللياقه
الدبلوماسيه والاخلاقيه واي شيء اخر على
حد وصفه
ينضم لنا الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس سيدي ايهاب
اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه اليوم
هل يجب ان تؤخذ هذه التصريحات والتهديدات
القادمه من كبار المسؤولين الروسي
باستخدام السلاح النووي والحرب العالميه
الثالثه على محمل الجد بشكل مختلف في
امريكا والغرب سيد ايهاب
اهلا بحضرتك استاذ خالد واهلا بكل
المشاهدين اينما كانوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عقيدتها النوويه واستراتيجيتها
التي تتعامل بها فيما يتعلق بامنها القومي
دائما تفترض ان التهديد الخارجي ايا كان
حتى لو كان صغيرا هو تهديد للامن القومي
الامريكي ومن الممكن ان يؤثر عليها بالسلب
لذلك اي تصريحات تاتي من قبل روسيا في هذا
التوقيت الذي يمر فيه العالم بهذه الحرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا تؤخذ على محمل الجد
لكن هل بناء عليها تتصرف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتستبق الاحداث او تحاول ان
تطبق عقيدتها التي دائما تطبقها في
الملفات النزاعيه وهي انها تذهب الى يعني
الحدث قبل ان ياتي هو اليها لا تتعمل بهذا
الموقع ولذلك جاءت التصريحات من قبل
المسؤولين الامريكيين انه لا دلاله حتى
الان ان روسيا تنوي استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه لكن هذا لا يعني ان الولايات
المتحده غير مستعده لا هي مستعده مستعده
تماما ولديها خطط واستراتيجيات يعني قريبه
المدى ومتوسطه المدى بالاضافه طبعا طويله
المدى للتعامل مع اي مخاوف نوويه تاتي من
الجانب
من كثره هذه التصريحات لم تاتي الاشاره من
اي مسؤول امريكيه عن تغير في طبيعه
التعامل اذا ما استخدمت روسيا سلاح نووي
لا توجد يعني اي رسائل واضحه او مباشره او
تصريحات توحي بذلك من قبل واشنطن سيدي هي
واشنطن لديها خطط تعامل نووي جاهزه دائما
هو معروفه حتى لروسيا
والخطط الروسيه ايضا معروفه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وللاسف الشديد هذه
الخطط النوويه يعني لا اريد ان اقول لك
استاذ خالد مبنيه على تدمير العالم تقريبا
لان اطلاق الصواريخ سواء كان من روسيا او
من امريكا اذا ما الحرب العالميه الكبرى
التي يخشاها الجميع ستكون مدمره للكوكب
لذلك هناك دائما نقاط رجوع لدى كل من
الطرفين يعلمان جيدا انه بعد هذه النقاط
اذا ما تم تجاوزها فلا رجوع فلذلك هناك
دائما تواصل عسكري مباشر بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده في احلق الظروف كما نحن
الان يعني اليوم كثيرون يتوقعون مثلا انه
لا يوجد تواصل روسي امريكي عسكري لا هناك
تواصل وتواصل تواصل قوي جدا وكبير جدا
لهذه النقطه تحديدا لمنع ان يقع العالم في
دائره الحرب النوويه التي ستكون دمارا
ووبانا على الجميع الحديث والتلويح
بالسلاح النووي من قبل روسيا او التلويح
بالرد من قبل من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو من مجرد يعني نوع من انواع
الردع لكن هذا الردع لن يتطور الا اذا
حدثت بعض الامور التي من الممكن ان تزيد
الطين كما مثلا
اعلنت بريطانيا انها ستزود اوكرانيا
بقنابل تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
وبالتالي هذا التحرك من بريطانيا دعا
روسيا ان تقول اعتقد بالامس قال بوتين انه
اذا ما تمت هذه الخطوه من بريطانيا فان
الروسي سترد بنفس هذه الخطوه هذا سيضعنا
على بدايات الخطوات الاولى الاحتماليه ان
نكون للاسف الشديد على ابواب حرب نوويه
هناك من يرى بان هذه التصريحات هي مجرد
خطوات تكتيكيه روسيه هدفها التاثير على
وتيره تسليح دول النيتو لاوكرانيا يعني هل
يمكن وضع هذه التصريحات بالفعل ضمن هذا
الاطار وهل لها اي تاثير ونحن نرى الكثير
من الدعم العسكري باسلحه نوعيه يعني تزيد
هذه الاسلحه من نوعيتها يوما بعد يوم
فبالتالي هلا اي تاثير مثل هذه التصريحات
على موازين القوه على ارض المعركه اليوم
اتفق مع وجهه النظر هذه لكن للاسف الشديد
النوعيه التسليح هي التي تقود روسيا اليوم
لاستخدام
التهديد بالسلاح النووي روسيا منذ اليوم
الاول تقريبا لهذه الحرب نتذكر بانها قامت
بتدريبات ردع نووي ووضعت استراتيجيه
غواصتها الاستراتيجيه النوويه في حالات
تاهب قصوى والى اخره وكل فتره تخرج علينا
الاداره الروسيه او نائب رئيس المجلس
الامن القومي الروسي السيد بتصريحات
متعلقه بهذا الاطار لكن انا اعتقد ان
النقطه المفصليه اليوم التي من الممكن ان
تحرك العالم في اي اتجاه اخر هي نقطه ان
بريطانيا ستزود اوكرانيا باسلحه تحتوي على
البقايا اليورانيوم كما يسمونها ستكون
للاسف الشديد هذه الخطوه يعني في الاتجاه
الخطا من قبل بريطانيا وربما تؤدي الى
تطور التصريحات الروسيه بدلا من ان تبقى
في اطار التصريحات التي هي اكثر من عام
الان لكي تنتقل لمرحله ربما التنفيذ على
ارض الواقع بشكل او باخر وهذا ربما يضع
الولايات المتحده وروسيا القوتين الاكبر
نوويا في العالم في مواجهه مباشره قريبا
جدا
لاوكرانيا بقنابل تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم هي هي النقطه الفعليه تراها التي
يمكن ان تجعل البوتين يستخدم السلاح
النووي اليس في ذلك الامر شيئا من
المبالغه خاصه ان هناك من يقول مثلا بان
هذه النقطه النهائيه هي الدخول المباشر من
قبل القوات النيتو في هذه الحرب
الاوكرانيه هنا يمكن للروس ان يستخدموا
سلاح النووي ما رايك في هذا الكلام بكل
تاكيد لان اليوم اوكرانيا ليس لديها سلاح
نووي وعندما تزود بسلاح شبه نووي يعني
القنابل التي تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
هي قنابل شبه نوويه فيها ماده نوويه ستؤدي
الى وجود احداث اشعاع يصيب الجنود ويصيب
البيئه ويؤثر بشكل سلبي جدا الاماكن التي
تضرب فيها هذه القنابل هذا سيعطي لروسيا
المبرر التام لكي تستخدم على الاقل تقدير
نفس نوعيه القنابل التي استخدمت ضدها وهو
مقاله بوتين بالامس هذا التطور من شانه ان
يجعل الامور اكثر التهابا واكثر قربا من
احتماليه اتخاذ قرار باستخدام ماذا لو
استخدمت روسيا سلاحا تكتيكيا ربما لتغيير
قواعد اللعبه على الارض طبعا من الممكن ان
تستخدم روسيا يعني عندما يستخدم
نعم روسيا عندما يستخدم ضدها السلاح
النووي المنظم بشكل او باخر من الممكن هي
تصاعد من جانبها باستخدام السلاح النووي
استخدمت روسيا سلاح النووي تكتيكي الان في
في هذه الحرب للتغيير قواعد اللعبه على
الارض اذا ما بدات الامور تسير اكثر نحو
الجيش الاوكراني والغرب يعني في هذه الحرب
لن تستخدم السلاح النووي الا في حاله
واحده فقط اذا وجدت نفسها تخسر هذه الحرب
او انت طال اوكرانيا بضرباتها العسكريه
بناء على الاسلحه النوعيه التي حصلت عليها
الداخل الروسي بشكل مكثف وليس وليس بشكل
ضربات هنا وهناك كل فتره يعني روسيا تضرب
في الداخل ولكن يعني كل فتره يعني صاروخ
يقع في مصنع في منطقه سكنيه لكن ليس بشكل
دائم اذا ما تطورت الحرب الى هذه المرحله
اعتقد ان روسيا ستستخدم السلاح النووي
واعتقد ايضا ان استخدام روسيا للسلاح
النووي التكتيكي في هذا التوقيت لن يستدعي
تدخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نوويا
ايضا يعني اعتقد ان
المواجهه النوويه المباشره بين روسيا
وامريكا ربما ستكون بسبب استخدام مباشر
لروسيا او للنيتو لهذه الصواريخ النوويه
لازم يكون هناك طرف بدا بضرب صواريخ نوويه
حقيقيه وليس التكتيكيه التكتيكيه ستستدعي
ردود تكتيكيه ايضا ربما تبقى في الاطار
الحدود المكاني لاوكرانيا لكن كيف تتطور
الامر نوويه الكبرى سيكون هناك يعني تداخل
اما للنيتو او للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بشكل مباشر ضد روسيا شكرا جزيلا لك من
واشنطن الباحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس
تحياتي
في تطورات الصراع الفلسطينيه الاسرائيلي
دعا بيان مشترك لوزراء خارجيه مجلس
التعاون الخليجي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى تحمل مسؤولياتها في الرد
على كافه الاجراءات والتصريحات التي
تستهدف الشعب الفلسطيني كما حتى البيان
لاداره الامريكيه على القيام بدورها
للتوصل الى حل عادل وشامل ودائم للصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي تضمن البيان رساله
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي يعلنون فيها
ادانتهم لتصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
بازاله بلده حواره وانكار وجود الشعب
الفلسطيني
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل توجه كويتي نحو
الاستغناء عن 2000 معلم ومعلمه بنهايه
العام الدراسي الجاري واحلالهم بمواطنهم
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت احصائيات خاصه
بوزاره التربيه والتعليم في الكويت عن خطه
الاستغناء عن الفي مدرس وافد واحلالهم
بمواطنين بنهايه العام الدراسي الجاري في
14 تخصصا تعليميا المشمولون بخطه الاحلال
للمعلمين ينتمون الى 24 جنسيه من مختلف
دول العالم وفقا للاحصائيه التي نشرتها
صحيفه القبس بينت الاحصائيه ان 82% من
المعلمين المشمولين بالاحلال هم من
الجنسيات المصريه
في رابع ايام شهر رمضان المبارك بلغ عدد
التصاريح الصادره عن طريق تطبيقينوسك
وتوكلنا لاداء العمره اكثر من مليونين
وثمانمائه الف تصريح فيما يستمر توافد
المعتمرين والزوار على مطار الملك عبد
العزيز الدولي في جده وعملت اداره المطار
على تحويل المزيد من رحلات شركات الطيران
الاجنبيه المنتظمه ذات الحموله العاليه من
ركاب العمره من الصاله الشماليه الى مجمع
صلاه الحجاج
والصلاه الحج والعمره وذلك وفق الطاقه
الاستيعابيه كما يستمر المعتمرون في
القدوم عبر الرحلات الدوليه والداخليه في
المطار
من مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
ينضم الينا مراسل العربي عبد الالواح عبد
الحميد عبد الواحد مرحبا بك كيف تبدو
الحركه الان في المطار
نعم خالد اهلا وسهلا بك نحن نقف الان في
هذه الصاله التي يعني ياتي من خلالها
المعتمرون والمسافرون بشكل عام في هذا
الممر ياتي كل تقريبا خمس دقائق من من
اليمين ياتي المسافرون على الطيران
الداخلي ومن اليسار ياتي المسافرون على
الطيران الدولي هذا فيما يتعلق بالصاله
رقم واحد اضافه الى الصلاه الاخرى في مطار
الملك عبد العزيز نتحدث عن صاله الحجاج
وكذلك صار رقم واحد اضافه الى صاله اخرى
التي تستقبل المعتمرين الصاله الشماليه
على سبيل المثال التي
تحال اليها الطائرات ذات الاشغال العالي
لمنع التزاحم داخل صلاه واروقه المطار
فيما يتعلق خالد كذلك حتى بالطرق التي
والمسارات التي يستطيع من خلالها
المعتمرون الوصول الى مكه المكرمه نتحدث
عن طبعا قطار الحرمين نتحدث كذلك حتى
سيارات الاجره اضافه الى الحافلات التي
يستطيع من خلالها المعتمرون الوصول الى
المسجد الحرام نشاهد هذه الوفود من
المعتمرين الذين ربما وصلوا من خارج
السعوديه حيث ياتي هؤلاء المعتمرون بشكل
مستمر عبر هذه الصاله يعني اضافه الى ان
الاعداد المتعلقه بالطاقه الاستيعابيه
لمطار الملك عبد العزيز نتحدث عن 11 الف
مسافر نتحدث عن المسافرين والمغادرين
والقادمين هذا هذه هي الطاقه الاستيعابيه
اضافه الى 350 350 الف مسافر خلال الفتره
السابقه في الايام الاولى من شهر رمضان
هذه الاحصائيات التي حصلنا عليها والارقام
طبعا فيما يتعلق خالد حتى
بالمجموعات التي تاتي الى مطار جده
المجموعات التي تاتي للعمره كل هذه
المجموعات يتم
احالتها حتى فيما يتعلق
بالصالات الامتعه او المناطق الخاصه
بالامتعه تكون بشكل مستقل حيث كما تعلم
المجموعات كي لا تسبب اي ازدحام في هذه
الصلاه هذه كل التفاصيل المتعلقه بمطار
الملك عبد العزيز خالد من خلال الصلاه
الثلاث التي ياتي من خلالها المعتمرون
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الواحد عبد الحميد
مراسل العربيه من مطار الملك عبد العزيز
ونبقى في مكه المكرمه حيث لا تقتصروا
زيارتها على اداء العمره بل تحضر رحله
الزائر والمعتمر بتجربه ثقافيه فريده حيو
حراء الثقافي هو احد ابرز الوجهات التي
تثري تجربه الزوار عبر معارض ومتاحف
متعدده سلسله من الحرمين مع الزميل سلطان
السلمي
[موسيقى]
يقع الحي الثقافي على مساحه تزيد عن 67
الف متر مربع ويسهم في اثراء التجربه
المعرفيه والثقافيه للزوار عبر مكوناته
المتنوعه ويضم المشروع مركز الزوار ومتحف
القران الكريم كذلك معرض الوحي وطريق
الصعود الى الغار المكان جمع بين الرساله
التوعويه والرساله ايضا الترفيهيه
السياحيه فكل من يزور هذا المكان بامكانه
ان يتحصل على المعلومات والمعارف التي
تكون من مصادر موثوقه اضافه الى ذلك اماكن
ترفيهيه له ولعائلته تحظى المواقع
الاسلاميه والتاريخيه في السعوديه
باهتمام ملحوظ من قبل الجهات المعنيه التي
تعمل على تطويرها لجعلها وجهه سياحيه
ومقصدا لزوار الداخل والخارج من مكه
المكرمه
سلطان السلمي العربيه
رابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل
امطار المتفاوته على العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض وتوقعات باستمرارها حتى غدا
الاثنين
تلوحوا بالنووي مجددا والنيت يصف تهديدات
موسكو بالخطيره وغير المسؤوله
وزراوه خرجات الدول الخليجيه يبحثون
واشنطن او يحثون واشنطن على التوصل لحل
شامل ودائم لقضيه فلسطين
نحو ثلاثه ملايين تصريح للعمره في رمضان
حتى الان والتوافد كبير على المسجد الحرام
[موسيقى]
وبدو الرصد الالي لمخالفات ملاحقه وتعطيل
لحركه سيارات الاسعاف في السعوديه
وموجه امطار متفاوته تعلق الدراسه في
ثمانيه عشره مدينه سعوديه والتوقعات
باستمرار الحاله الجويه حتى يوم
رصد فات ملاحقه سيارات الاسعاف او عدم
افساح الطريق لها لم يعد يدويا بل اصبح
اليا بدءا من اليوم بعد تركيب كاميرات في
مؤخره سيارات الاسعاف وكاميرات اخرى في
مقدمتها لرصد المخالفات اليا وارسالها الى
الانظمه المروريه لاصدار المخالفه ورد
الان بلاغ الى الهلال الاحمر وسنرافق هذه
السياره سياره الاسعاف لمشاهده اليه رصد
المخالفات الجديده واقعيا في شوارع الرياض
خلال دقائق فقط من انطلاق سياره الهلال
الاحمر لمباشره بلاغ تم رصد ما يقارب ثلاث
مخالفات لعدم افساح الطريق لسياره الاسعاف
المخالفات ايضا لملاحقه سياره الاسعاف
مستمره احنا عندنا طريقتين لرص المخالفات
الطريق الاولى بالكاميرات المثبته في
مركبه الاسعاف كاميرا اماميه وكاميرا
خلفيه بضغط الزر يبدا التسجيل 20 ثانيه
عشر ثواني قبل ضغط الزر يتم حفظها وعشر
ثواني من بعدها بعدها يتم رفع المخالفه او
المقطع الى العمليات
لرصدها الطريقه الثانيه عن طريق نظام باشر
نظام المرور رسم المخالفات بالجوال يتم
تسجيل ثلاث صور الصوره الاولى
لوحه السياره الصوره الثانيه للسياره
كامله والصوره الثانيه للسياره بالمحيط
الحولها المخالفات هذه كذلك ترفع ولكن
ترصد مباشره فرقه عن المخالفات اللي مدمجه
في كابينه الاسعاف انه يتم فلترتها في
البدايه خلال واحده للهلال الاحمر وفي اقل
من نصف ساعه رصدت عشرات المخالفات
لملاحقه سياره الاسعاف هذا النظام الالي
الجديد لرصد المخالفات سيساهم كثيرا بالحد
من هذا النوع من المخالفات لرفع مستوى
السلامه المروريه في السعوديه من الرياض
نواف عزيز العربيه
ثمانيه عشره مدينه سعوديه علقت فيها
الدراسه الحضوريه اليوم بعد موجه امطار
متفاوته وتقلبات في حاله الطقس منها مكه
المكرمه والطائف والجده والجزر المركز
الوطني للارصاد اصدر تقارير تحذر من بطول
امطار غزيره على هذه المناطق كما صدرت
تحضيراتون في وقت سابق من هطول امطار
رعديه وعاصفه ترابيه على غالبيه مناطق
السعوديه بدلا من يوم الجمعه الماضي
وتستمر حتى يوم غد من الاثنين
[موسيقى]
من رياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز نواف مرحبا بك قبل ساعتين تقريبا
ايضا كانت قد شهدت الرياض امطار ايضا ربما
غزيره نسبيا لكن هل ما زالت الفرصه مهيئه
لهطول امطار اكثر خلال ساعه القادمه
نعم خالد للتو قبل دقائق هطلت امطار
متوسطه ونحن نتواجد الان في هذا المكان
وساترك لكم الصوره الان لمشاهده الامطار
التي تهطل الان على العاصمه الرياض وعلى
عموم الرياض وفعليا كان للرياض نصيب من
الامطار التي هطلت على مختلف مناطق
السعوديه بدءا من صباح اليوم من الساعات
الاولى باكرا هطلت الامطار بشكل متوسط الى
غزير اذا استطعنا ان نقول غزير فهو ربما
يقترب من ذلك وعلى الرغم من ذلك خالد لم
يتم تعليق الدراسه في الرياض على الرغم من
ان صلاحيه تعليق الدراسه ممنوحه لادارات
التعليم في مختلف مناطق السعوديه بناء على
الظروف المناخيه وغيرها الامطار الان
مستمره في الرياض وحسب التوقعات ان تستمر
حتى نهايه يوم غد الاثنين والاجواء تغيرت
في الرياض درجه الحراره
انخفضت الى 16 درجه مئويه مع هطول الامطار
الان ربما تصل درجه الحراره الى ثلاثه
وعشرين درجه مئويه قبل قليل كانت 25 درجه
مئويه الاجواء متغيره حقيقه خالد والرياض
وسكان الرياض غير معتادين على هذه الاجواء
الماطره خاصه في شهر رمضان كما نشاهد الان
نحن نتواجد على شارع العليا نشاهد الان
السكان ياتون الى هذا الممشى لممارسه
الرياضه والمشي قبل ساعه من اذان المغرب
والافطار هنا ايضا مركز الملك عبد الله
المالي نشاهد كيف اصبح مع الغيوم التي
جاءت بعد الامطار وبدا من الساع الاولى من
صباح هذا اليوم على الرغم من التوقعات
التي تفيد باستمرار هطول الامطار ايضا
خالد الدفاع المدني
كعادته يحذر من
الابتعاد عن عدم الاقتراب من مجاري السيول
والاوديه وايضا الابتعاد عن مناطق تجمع
الامطار الاجواء رائعه هنا في الرياض خاصه
مع موسم رمضان الذي اطلقته وزاره الثقافه
العديد من الخيارات متاحه
لسكان الرياض الاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء
الفريده والتي لا تحدث في كل عام خاصه في
شهر رمضان لا زالت الامطار مستمره ونحن
نشهدها الان سوف تستمر بالتاكيد وفقا
لتوقعات المركز الوطني للارصاد حتى نهايه
يوم الغد مصحوبه برياح تحمل الاتربه امطار
خير وبركه ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك نواف
عزيز مراسل العربيه من الرياض
مدينه حائل شمال السعوديه بصناعه المباخر
باشكال واحجام مختلفه هذه الصناعه تورثها
حرفيون عبر الاجيال ونشات قبل نحو 150
عاما التفاصيل مع جزاع
[موسيقى]
صناعه المباخر في مدينه حائل شمال
السعوديه حرفه يدويه نشات قبل نحو 150
عاما قام عليها حرفيون مهره توارثها عبر
الاجيال احدها هؤلاء سعود الجميل الذي
احترف هذه المهنه منذ نعومه اظفاره انا
ابن عائله
احترفتها المهنه مهنه صناعه المباخر
الحيليه اكثر من 100 وخمسين عام ولله
الحمد وتورثناها ابا عن جد حتى انا عملت
فيها منذ الصغر مع اهلي واتقنت هذه الشغله
وهي الشغله عباره عن خشب اثل
يقص كذا ويخرج من هذا الى عمليه العظم الى
بعده عمليه النحت حتى تكتمل مبخره كامله
مزينه بالقمور والصاج
المرايا متكامله كامله
ادوات تقليديه بدائيه صنعت شكل المبخره
الحائليه الذي لم يتغير حتى مع توفر
الالات الحديثه صناعه الواحده تحتاج الى
الدقه كما يستغرق تزيينها من ساعتين الى
خمس ساعات وفق الشكل والحجم طبعا هذه
المدخنه صنعها الوالد قبل 50 سنه بطول 60
سم وزن عشر كيلو وكذلك هذه المدخنه بنفس
العام رحمه الله صناعهم لو تبي تلاحظ
الفرق بين صناعه هالمدخنه هذه وهذه اللي
قبل خمسين سنه وهذه 15 يوم له الان تجد
انه ليس فرق بين صناعتهم لان الصناعه جوده
واصيله وسعر هذه المبخره حتى الان 1500
ريال
[موسيقى]
تعد المباخر الحائليه رمزا تقليديا عند
استقبال الضيوف لنشر روائح زكيه تدخل
البهجه في نفوس الزوار وتتميز بشكلها
المتفرد واحجامها المختلفه حتى انها باتت
ايقونه مجسمه تتزين بها الميادين العامه
من مدينه حائل
جزاعا معصي العربيه
الاسلام ربط شعائره التعبديه بحركه
الاجرام السماويه تقويم مع خالد الزعك
[موسيقى]
اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم لا منهم شافوا
شخص بعد انقطاع طويل يقولون له هل لهلاله
فهي كنايه عن العتب اللطيف زور وارحامكم
ولا تقطعون بهم خاصه بهالشهر الفضيل
والهلال هو الجزء المضاع من حافه القمر
ويكون مثل الظفر ويكون في الاربعه ايامنا
الاول والاربعه ايامنا الاخيره من الشهر
الهجري يا بدر كم سهرت عليك نواظره ويا
غصن كم ناحت عليك بلا بلو البدر يكمل في
كل شهر مره وهلال وجهك كل يوم
كامل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاسلام ربط شعائره تعبديه بحركه الاجرام
السماويه فنحن لا نصلي الا على حركات
الشمس اقم الصلاه لدلوك شمس الى غسق الليل
وقران الفجر ان قران الفجر كان مشهودا
ونحن لا نصوم الا على رؤيه القمر صوموا
لرؤيته وافطروا لرؤيته فالشمس والقمر لها
مكانه عظيمه في الشريعه الاسلاميه للشمس
ينبغي لها ان تدرك القمر ولا الليل سابق
النهار وكل في فلك
يسبحون
[موسيقى]
بعد العواصف العاتيه التي ضربت ولايه
واصل السلطات الامريكيه عمليات البحث
والانقاذ على اثر الاعصار القوي الذي
شهدته الولايه حيث لقي ما لا يقل عن 26
شخصا مسرحهم كما يعتقد ان الكثيرين ايضا
ما زالوا عالقين تحت حطام المنازل التي
دمرها الاعصار ودمرها الاعصار ايضا العديد
من القرى والمناطق الريفيه وتسبب في سقوط
الاشجار وقطع خطوط الطاقه
[موسيقى]
تستمر الحرائق في اسبانيا حيث اتت على
4000 هكتار مع تخوف السلطات المحليه من
تفاقم الوضع بسبب الظروف الجويه السيئه
التي تعيق جهود اخماد النيران هذه الحرائق
تسببت حتى الان في 1500 شخص في مقاطاعتي
كاستيلون
في شرق البلاد
[موسيقى]
وخارجيه الدول الخارجيه يحثون واشنطن على
التوصل لحل لحل شامل ودائم لقضيه فلسطين
نحو 30 ثلاثه ملايين تصريح للعمره في
رمضان حتى الان وتوافد كبير على المسجد
الحرام
[موسيقى]
رصد القليل لمخالفات ملاحقه وتعطيل لحركه
سيارات الاسعاف في السعوديه
موجه امطار متفاوته تعلق الدراسه في 18
مدينه سعوديه والتوقعات باستمرار الحاله
الجويه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]